very rapidly went to from making not a
lot of money to
millions of dollars a year in profit um
to my second year
uh doing almost 20 million dollars in
profit
uh and that that that fundamentally i
think ruined
me in a lot of ways earlier on because
i saw that as my my benchmark
[Music]
what's going on everyone uh happy sunday
this is uh coming from downtown austin
uh wanted to talk to you about one of
the most profound belief and perspective
shifts that i've had over the last few
years
um and i think 2020 was that year for me
uh where i made one of the most profound
internal shifts
and uh the shift has yielded me
unbelievable amounts of decreases in
anxiety
uh for me and honestly just increases my
increase my level of certainty and i can
understand
why so many people fail to a much higher
degree
and i think one of the biggest curses
that i had earlier on in my career is
that
um you know within months
i went from it's just everything kind of
aligned for me
um mind you after five years of uh
eating [ __ ]
uh but nonetheless things did align for
me
um and very rapidly went to from making
not a lot of money to millions of
dollars a year in profit um
to my second year uh doing almost 20
million dollars in profit
uh and that that that fundamentally i
think ruined
me in a lot of ways earlier on because
i saw that as my my benchmark you know
what i mean i saw that as like if it's
if a business is not doing this then
it's failing we're doing something wrong
and i think that it was a really
poisonous viewpoint for me
or toxic viewpoint and uh i want to
share with you what what what i've
shifted to
and what has been such a dramatic
improvement in my life and i think
my business so when i look at investors
and people who make a lot more money
than me and people have much bigger
businesses than me
uh i see this common thread of
looking at it from an investor's time
horizon and so i feel like in
entrepreneurship everything is about
tomorrow everything's about this week
everything's about this month and making
payroll and all
you know you have all the day-to-day
things but you get so much you get so
caught
in the monthly goals and weekly goals
that you forget to make the long-term
investments that are important and not
urgent
and when i look at the billionaires of
the world and all of them are trying to
build you know
escape paths to mars to me i see that
i'm sure there's the cool factor but the
fact that they're all kind of thinking
about the stuff
just leads me to think that they're
thinking on such a larger time horizon
than the rest of humanity which is
probably one of the reasons that they're
more successful
and uh one of the things to think about
this is kind of
fast versus inevitable and i have tried
to shift my perspective to
wanting to do tasks and actions on a
repeated basis that i know
that if i repeat them over a long enough
time horizon
will lead me to inevitably accomplishing
my goal
and so what it does by shifting that way
is i look at
tasks i look at projects i look at
initiatives in a very different light
i also am i mean i wasn't super affected
by competition
in general mentally because of other
things but i think this has been
probably the last nail on the coffin for
me in terms of like
well so and so is making more or
whatever right the things that we do to
compare ourselves
if you remove the time horizon and think
of
uh not next year but maybe next decade
right
i've been using five years because that
is a timeline that i feel like i can
wrap my head around and israel for me
um i had a mentor reach out to me and he
was like and you know this guy sold his
thing for
three 3.4 billion and he's like bro you
need a hundred year timeline
and um i i took that in i accept that
uh but i it was it's not real for me yet
and so five years is something that is
real for me that i can believe in
and so uh what that does
is if you think about time as an
inevitable force that's going to move
forward one way or another
think about for a second how and this is
for me
do i see time as a threat do i see time
as a liability something that i'm always
saying is working against me or
is time an asset that is working for me
and i think this has been the single
greatest shift in perspective
for me is now seeing if i extend my time
horizon
then time stops being a liability and a
threat and becomes an asset
and how things compound over time now
works to assist me rather than
hinder me and so i'll give you a simple
example
so uh i have never believed in seo
right or really even inbound marketing
and
i have had a major shift in perspective
on this uh probably in the last 12
months
and the reason for that is because you
know if you your first 12 months of
of doing you know seo and i'm saying
that as a general
as a catch all time really just any
inbound marketing and that is not
paid advertising that results in people
because that's technically kind of still
outbound right you're you're putting ads
out there and then getting people to
respond rather than
basically pool based marketing where
you're putting you're creating a water
hole for people to come towards right
and so i've i've never really invested
much thought into
inbound stuff at all i mean the only
example of that is really this kind of
vlog slash podcast which i never did for
uh
for really any business purposes it's
just more for me to document my journey
um but nonetheless uh
thinking about this in terms of that
perspective of and i've been talking to
people who are like oh yeah we have this
you know it's taken us
five years to build this asset but now
this asset creates 3 000 applications a
month for our
for our software or for our whatever
right
and i think to myself i'm like man just
building a machine
that just consistently month over month
creates more
and more and more inbound interest
is just wildly compelling to me and so i
think to myself
okay sure we're gonna have our outbound
things uh both outbound in terms of
manual outbound with people
cold call call email etc you know cooldm
but also we have our
outbound with paid advertising across
platforms but the kind of the third
piece of this
is what can we quote invest in
that if i did it over five years i
believe it would be unreasonable for me
to not have built
another channel that is reliable and
sustainable and enduring
and so you'll probably see some more
things for me in the next 12 months
along that line because i think it's
really awesome and i want to use
compound
growth to my advantage rather than as a
hindrance rather than something that i
compare myself to and feel
always inadequate and so what i think
that the shift from the
ceo to investor mindset has helped me
with is
the stress that i put on myself for like
quarterly goals
and looking at someone else who might
have started at the same time as me and
is doing better than me
because then i get to think to myself
okay but we're not comparing ourselves
now we're comparing ourselves to what's
going to happen in
20 years right will their company still
be here and i'm trying to build
something that endures that lasts
that maybe even can be passed on to a
future generation and i don't think
those were ever thoughts of mine when i
was starting my entrepreneurial career
and i wish they had been
and so i don't know where you're at
right now but maybe if you can if you
can take that perspective and think to
yourself what could i create that and
what tasks did i do what projects could
i invest in that
even if they don't pay off this quarter
or next quarter even the next 12 months
i think that it would be inevitable that
i would have a disproportionate payoff
five years from now and obviously that
begets the obvious you know the
the the single greatest constraint that
most people have which is they can't do
anything consistently
but i believe i can do things
consistently and i think that many of
the people listening to this can do
things consistently
and so if you have that character
trailer already you've developed that
discipline
i feel like using that discipline to
invest in things that are going to
create
disproportionate returns is a good use
of
time right for us and so i'll give you a
real example
around this we're looking at doing an
initiative
on the gym launch in our dremels company
uh related to just generating more you
know inbound applications and whatnot
and i was talking to our gm about it and
i was saying listen let's let's not
think about that for like this quarter
i mean we can start now but let's not
measure the roi until you know next year
and i don't think i would ever have said
something like that
a year or two ago i don't even think it
would even be a thought
um but it's it's been wildly freeing
because
there's so much less pressure around
initiatives and i think it actually
improves the quality of the initiative
and the execution
of the team because they're not
immediately being like oh it's been a
week and it's not working so we're
failing right
and so um let me give you another really
good
nugget that i've had recently around
this which is
um rather than looking at
week-over-week month-over-month sales
growth
instead i asked myself the question
what one thing if i tripled it in our
company
what non-sales related you know what not
in revenue
related thing that if i were to triple
it it would be unreasonable to believe
that my company would not triple
as well and for me that was inbound
qualified or i'm saying inbound but just
number of qualified applications
generated that was a metric that i was
like okay
sometimes when you're increasing the
number of applications that are coming
in
uh you have a new sales person or new
sales team
and their their close rate is low it
happens right it's part of scaling a
business
but over a long enough time horizon it
would be unreasonable for me to believe
that if i were to triple my number of
applications
uh i would not see a you know a
proportional increase in sales
and so what's interesting to me is that
if i can i've never actually thought
about a leading indicator because i have
leading indicators on churn
which is like customer activation and i
talk about that in other stuff
but i've never actually had a leading
indicator on growth which is
fascinating to me that i've never had
this which is like hilarious
but actually measuring the number of
sales accepted leads and so that is
that's defined as a lead that the sales
team accepts
because they showed and are qualified
right they are the type of person
uh who who we can serve uh you know they
have the size business that we work with
you know and they showed up and they
have interest right so that would be a
sales qualified lead
and so trying to say i want to increase
sales by five percent a month is a fine
goal the thing is is that there are so
many other variables that can affect it
in a short time horizon like that
whereas saying i want to increase our
number of inbound applications by five
percent per month
is far more
consistent and reasonable to do and so
if you thought about like a line
right if i increa i know that i can
increase through consistent activity
the number of inbound uh applications
either through adding more people to
outreach
uh creating more channels for content um
and then you know obviously there's the
paid side which is you could add another
platform etc right
and so if i if i draw that line
that is something i can consistently do
and so when i'm thinking about growing
my business
and hitting a goal like tripling it
right in the next five years
and i think okay well then let's take
let's take our
sales qual sales qualified leads right
and let's draw that as our line
and that's going to be our baseline
right that's what we're going to focus
all our attention on
the day-to-day activities around that
those are going to be like the stock
market right they're
they're going to be up and down up and
down up and down and i think most of us
are looking at such small time horizons
it looks crazy
but if you look at it from an investor's
perspective in terms of years or decades
then you can really see the truth and
the reason that a stock will go up over
a decade is simply because of the true
economic value that a company is
providing right
and so for me a leading indicator of
growth would be the number of interested
inquiries that we get
and so that is actually going to be my
primary predictive metric that i will be
driving
because i know that of course we're
going to change processes sure we might
change crms you know we might change
our funnel or our sales like all these
things are small things but
if i can simply increase the number of
qualified applications of people who
want to
for example grow their gym uh by 3x in
the next five years
then i can reasonably believe that i
would be able to achieve it
and thinking that way it's just been
amazing and so
that is what i'm dedicated to doing and
some of these smaller projects
which for me were like well this thing
isn't going to double our lead gen so i
don't want to do it
i've really shifted my perspective on
that and so i'm now looking at
uh reliable inflows it's like okay well
i think
this one thing can generate us 20 new
clients a month
that's not huge for us but it's it's
it's
noticeable and so okay well then how you
know how much does it take to
to invest in that how long do it you
know and and and let's start it let's
start the let's start the snowball right
and so that's one of the that's what i
was talking my gm about and so we're
actually going to do this initiative
that i think will result in about
20 new clients a month and it's going to
take us time to get there but i
but i think it's it's going to be really
really uh valuable for us right
over the long haul especially and so let
me just take a quick look at my notes
because i wanted to make sure i'm not
missing anything for you
um do do uh
yeah i think that's i think that's um
that's my biggest thing
right that's that's pretty much my
message for for what my biggest
perspective shift has been
is thinking about a five-year time
horizon shifting from ceo to shareholder
uh shifting from ceo to to board member
or advisor
and thinking about it over those time
horizons and i feel like if you can just
make that change
i wish i could explain to you how much
less stress i have
because if you know the company goes up
by a little bit or down by a little bit
one month over another month it just
it just doesn't affect me like it
doesn't affect my life in any way
and i feel like i had my ego so and this
is actually the last point that i had in
my notes which is
my ego is just so much less impacted
by the fluctuations of the business that
it's just
it's just phenomenally increased my
standard of living like i'm just
i'm just really not that stressed about
things you know
i just can't even express it to you and
so anyways this has been probably the
biggest lesson of 2020 for me
um and obviously 2020 for us was uh
we our profit was cut in half we did i
think 13.4 in profit last year and we
did i think six
six this year we're getting our final
books but around that this year in
profit which was technically my lowest
year of profit in a while
and um but i can truthfully tell you it
just really doesn't affect me because i
know it's a momentary business
disruption
because of a pandemic that
disproportionately affected my clients
than many you know than many other
industries
um and i don't think it'd be
unreasonable for me to believe that over
the next three years
right that we would we would not only
recover but grow past where we were
before
and so in thinking about that um
anyways i just it's been it's just
viewing time as an ally and not
an ally or an asset not a threat or a
liability and
once you can when i can hitch my cart to
something that is inevitable like the
past and
the passing of time um then i feel like
you're aligned
with forces that will grow you without
your permission
and so anyways i'll leave you with that
i hope you have an amazing day and keep
being awesome
catch you on the flip side
[Music]
[Applause]
you